>> Sean: MARYLAND G.O.P.
CONGRESSIONAL CANDIDATE KIM
KLACIK.
SHE CONTINUES TO HOLD
BALTIMORE’S DEMOCRATIC LEADERS
ACCOUNTABLE FOR THEIR FAILURES
PARTICULAR TO THE
AFRICAN-AMERICAN COMMUNITY.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> I WALK THE STREETS OF
BALTIMORE AND SEE WHAT COULD BE
ANDAND I WANT YOU TO SEE WHAT I
SEE.
I SEE A BALTIMORE THAT PICKS UP
TRASH.
THERE ARE PILES OF GARBAGE ALL
AROUND BALTIMORE.
IT MAKES LIFE UNSAFE FOR OUR
FAMILIES.
I’LL WORK WITH CITY LEADERS TO
GET BALTIMORE’S SOLID WASTE
BUREAU THE RESOURCES IT NEEDS.
>> Sean: ON FRIDAY SHE JOINED
THE EVER IMPORTANT, HARD-HITTING
NEW SHOW "THE VIEW" WHERE SHE
HAD A HEATED EXCHANGE WITH
COHOST JOY BEHAR AFTER
CRITICIZING HER FOR WEARING
BLACK FACE.
IT ENDED QUICKLY.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> IS DESTROYED SPEAKING?
THE SAME JOY IN BLACKFACE NOT
TOO LONG AGO.
COME ON.
>> THAT’S NOT TRUE.
EXCUSE ME.
THE BLACK COMMUNITY HAS MY BACK.
THEY KNOW --
>> THE BLACK COMMUNITY HAS MY
BACK.
>> Sean: HERE WITH MORE, KIM
KLACIK HERSELF.
CIVIL RIGHTS ATTORNEY, OH, MAN.
[LAUGHS]
LEO 2.0.
HE WON THE POLL FAIR AND SQUARE.
I WAS WRONG FRIDAY.
I HUMBLY APOLOGIZE.
I DON’T LIKE LOSING.
I’M NOT SICK OF WINNING.
YOU WIN, LEO.
>> Sean: WHERE DID YOU GET
THAT HAT?
I NEVER SAW A HAT LIKE THAT
BEFORE.
ALL RIGHT, KIM, LET ME GO TO
BALTIMORE.
THE THIRD HIGHEST SPENDING PER
CAPITA FOR STUDENT IN THE WORLD.
13 PUBLIC SCHOOLS WERE NOT A
SINGLE CHILD IS PROFICIENT IN
MATH IN BALTIMORE?
>> THAT’S ABSOLUTELY TRUE.
YOU CAN ADD TO THAT WE ACTUALLY
HAVE MORE DATA THAT CAME OUT AND
SAYS 9 OUT OF 10 BLACK MALE
STUDENTS DO NOT READ AT GRADE
LEVEL IN BALTIMORE CITY.
WE HAVE A PROBLEM WITH OUR
EDUCATION.
THAT’S WHY I’M A PROPONENT FOR
SCHOOL CHOICE.
WE HAVE A PROBLEM WITH CAREER
OPPORTUNITIES.
WE LACK THEM.
WE DON’T HAVE ANYTHING.
I’M PUSHING FOR
PRESIDENT TRUMP’S OPPORTUNITY
ZONES IN BALTIMORE CITY.
HE’S INVESTED 75 BILLION IN
OTHER CITIES DEMOCRATS HAVE LEFT
NEGLECTED.
WE NEED THAT IN BALTIMORE.
OF COURSE WE TALK ABOUT THE
IMPORTANCE OF FAMILY STRUCTURE.
YOU KNOW, SIMPLE THINGS WE CAN
DO TO DRIVE DOWN CRIME AND
VIOLENCE AND GET PEOPLE ECONOMIC
OPPORTUNITIES AND THAT’S WHAT WE
NEED TO DO.
>> Sean: YOU KNOW, LEO, I SEE
THIS AND YET DEMOCRATS GET
ELECTED.
LIBERAL DEMOCRATS HAVE BEEN
RUNNING STATES, BLUE STATES AND
CITIES INTO THE GROUND.
THEY FEEL ON LAW, ORDER, SAFETY,
SECURITY, EDUCATION.
THOSE ARE THE TWO MOST IMPORTANT
THINGS THAT THEY OUGHT TO BE
DOING RIGHT.
>> YOU’RE 100% RIGHT.
SCHOOL CHOICE IS A CIVIL RIGHTS
ISSUE OF THE DAY.
IT BREAKS THE POVERTY CYCLE.
WHAT KIM IS DOING IS IF KIM WINS
THIS ELECTION, IT WILL BREAK THE
DEMOCRATIC STRANGLEHOLD ON BLACK
VOTERS.
I HAVE TO WALK THE STREETS IN
BALTIMORE BECAUSE THIS ELECTION
IS KEY.
KID NEEDS TO WIN THIS ELECTION.
IT WILL SEND A MESSAGE THE
DEMOCRATIC POWER STRUCTURE THAT
THE BLACKS HAVE BROKEN AWAY.
KIM IS THE KEY TO BREAKING THAT
STRANGLEHOLD ON BLACKS BY THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
THAT’S WHY THEY ARE NERVOUS
ABOUT HIM.
ONE LAST POINT, JOY BEHAR, THE
BLACK COMMUNITY HAS YOUR BACK?
THAT’S WHAT I’M TALKING ABOUT.
THEY THINK OF US AS MONOLITHIC.
I DON’T HAVE JOY BEHAR’S BACK.
KIM DOESN’T.
TO HAVE HER SAY SHE HAS THE
BLACK COMMUNITIES BACK, THAT’S
INSULTING.
THAT’S OF JOE BIDEN STATEMENT.
>> Sean: KIM, YOUR RUNNING
THESE HARD-HITTING ADS AND
YOU’RE SAYING IT’S AN
INSTITUTIONAL FAILURE.
NATIONAL SAFETY, NO SECURITY.
NOTHING MEANT POVERTY.
DECADES OF LIBERAL DEMOCRATIC
RULE.
HOW IS YOUR MESSAGE RESONATING.
>> SO FAR, SO GOOD.
IT’S LIKE A LITTLE BIT OF THE
COMP SYNDROME.
WE HAVE SOME PEOPLE THAT DON’T
WANT TO ADMIT IT OUT LOUD AND WE
UNDERSTAND THAT BECAUSE OF THE
BACKLASH.
WE HAVE SOME PEOPLE SEVEN DAYS A
WEEK KNOCKING ON DOORS
CANVASSING IN FIVE DAYS A WEEK
THEY ARE REGISTERING VOTERS.
IN THESE AREAS ESPECIALLY THE
DANGEROUS NEIGHBORHOODS IN WEST
BALTIMORE, THERE ARE A LOT OF
PEOPLE THAT JUST AREN’T
REGISTERED TO VOTE AND SO WE ARE
TELLING THEM YOU’VE GOT TO BE
INVOLVED IN THIS PROCESS.
YOUR FUTURE, YOUR CHILDREN’S
FUTURE, THEY ALL DEPEND ON.
SO FAR, SO GOOD.
LIKE WE SAW, THERE IS A
NINE-POINT SWING FOR
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
I HAD A NINE-POINT SWING IN MY
SPECIAL ELECTION AND I THINK
WE’RE GOING TO DO EVEN BETTER
THIS TIME AROUND.
>> Sean: WILL THE POLLS THAT
SHOW AFRICAN-AMERICANS AND
HISPANIC-AMERICANS MOVING
TOWARDS DONALD TRUMP, WILL THEY
TRANSLATE INTO VOTES IN NOW 43
DAYS, LEO 2.0.
>> YES.
MICHAEL MOORE MADE A COMMENT
THAT JOE BIDEN HAS TAKEN BLACKS
IN MICHIGAN FOR GRANTED.
THERE’S BEEN A MIND-SET AND TO
SEE A BROKEN BY PEOPLE LIKE KIM
AND MYSELF, THE DEMOCRATS ARE
VERY NERVOUS BECAUSE BLACKS ARE
MOVING TOWARDS THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY LIKE THE HISPANICS.
ALL IT TAKES IS TO GO TO THE
BATTLEGROUND STATES WITH MORE
BLACK VOTING FOR TRUMP.